foreign
alhamdulillah
our family is extremely honored
that we have a Shaheed and that we are
the family of the Shahid inshallah
and I had to wait for my brother to
arrive before I told him something
when he was born
he had a twinkle in his eye
and I now know
that twinkle was the green bird
that had come into this Dunya and it was
constrained in his body and he couldn't
wait to leave and go back to Allah
when he was born
he had a smile
and he was a radiant smile and anybody
who's seen his picture can see this
smile alhamdulillah
and I now know
and I now see
that this smile was not something the
light in his smile was not something
that could be contained in his smile
alone they had to spread to the whole
Dunya
he had to spread to the whole Dunya
before he went back to Allah
when he was young
his brother Hassan and Hussein
I would tell them the stories of Hassan
and Hussein
because that's who they named after do
my father named them often
and it's strange
because all that time I thought he was
me who was telling the story to my baby
brother
but now I see
I was telling him a story of a Shaheed
but I was standing in front of a Shaheed
and I didn't even know it
I was telling him
the stories
of the princes of the Youth of Jannah
and I was sitting in front of the prince
of Jannah and I didn't even know it
Allah
Hussain our beloved Hussein
he is an example inshallah
of the need for the Youth of Islam
for the Youth to have Islam to live by
Islam and to die by Islam inshallah
once again I retrained my father's words
and I look forward to seeing you for
saying
soon because now I have one more story
to tell you and that will be your own
insurance